thank you both people here in person and
virtually for spending some time with me
uh there is a slack channel specifically
for this talk if any questions come up
as i'm talking about things please feel
free to type them into slack i probably
won't have time at the end of the talk
to talk about them from up here but i
will answer whatever you want to put in
there about anything related to this
so my talk for you today is called game
development in 8 bits
the subtitle for today's talk is stupid
nes tricks i use that name intentionally
um before i jump in there are i think
two initial questions we should get
clarified first off what is nes for
anyone who is not familiar with this
these letters indicate the nintendo
entertainment system it is a home video
game console produced by nintendo
shocking i know
released in the u.s in october 1985. so
this system is now 36 years old
the nintendo entertainment system was
the american redesign of nintendo's
japanese home video game console the
family computer or famicom which came
out two years earlier in 1983.
the us nes was internally the same exact
hardware
but the outside was redesigned to make
it look less like a toy and more like a
vcr
true story
both of these systems nintendo r d they
were given the
guideline for their design that at a
baseline the system needed to be able to
play a decent home version of nintendo's
hit arcade game donkey kong which came
out in 1981
worldwide smash really kind of put
nintendo on the map for a lot of people
um you can see the way donkey kong works
there is a lot of animation has a lot of
color
um
generally a a pretty good looking game
definitely dated
but to put into context how big of an
achievement donkey kong is uh
the predecessor home video game console
was the atari video computer system or
2600.
released in 1977 has this beautiful wood
grain front panel
has these joysticks that only have one
action button on them and the game that
the atari 2600 was built to play as a
baseline was this game called combat
two players they each control one of
these little tanks moving through a play
field of these kind of walls and
shooting at each other and spinning
around really fast when they get hit
this is the game the 2600 was built to
play and i think donkey kong is kind of
leaps and bounds beyond this
so inside that console the nes features
an mos technologies 6502 cpu
a very popular chip actually came out in
1975
10 years before the nes did
running for at the time a blazing fast
1.79 megahertz
it also features a custom ricoh designed
and manufactured picture processing unit
or ppu
uh this is kind of like the graphics
card of the nes this enables the nes to
do 256 by 240 pixels screen resolution
and it lets it show 64 colors
the nes also has two kilobytes of system
ram it has two kilobytes of video ram
that's all the memory you get inside the
system
uh it has no permanent storage of any
kind it has no operating system it has
no hardware clock there is nothing
everything the nes is gonna run it comes
off of the cartridge that you put into
it
which gives you space for 32 kilobytes
of actual game code and eight kilobytes
of graphics data so your whole game is
going to fit into 40 kilobytes
the second question we should get out of
the way is what exactly does 8-bit mean
kind of important
the bit if you are unaware is a binary
digit so one bit represents a 0 or a 1
an off or an on it has two possible
values and if you combine more bits
together you can represent a broader
range of things so if you have two bits
that gives you four possible values if
you have four bits you can do 16
and on and on and when you get to eight
bits uh this has a special name we call
that a byte and a single byte lets you
represent 256 different possible values
uh what makes the nes or other systems
like it an 8-bit computer is that it
processes data eight bits at a time
or to put that another way as far as the
nes is concerned everything in the
entire universe is ultimately
represented by a number between 0 and
255 we're going to see these numbers all
the time
so with that out of the way
let's dive in
i'm going to start by talking about
drawing graphics a very important thing
for a video game system to do
the nes as i mentioned has a screen
resolution of 256 by 240 pixels if i
multiply those two together we get 61
440 pixels in every screen of graphics
and because of the way the nes handles
color if we were to do things this way
you could fit four pixels in a byte
so that means you would need about 15
kilobytes to store a single screen of
graphics and that is a problem because
the nes has two kilobytes of video ram
so you you would not be able to display
a screen you can't fit it in memory
so the first problem we need to talk
about is how do you draw
a big screen full of graphics when you
only have two kilobytes to work with
for the nes and for many other game
systems of its time the answer is really
you get kind of abstract
uh you don't draw with pixels because
you can't the hardware just isn't
powerful enough to do it
so instead you draw with tiles
tiles for the nes are generally eight
pixels by eight pixels square
and those tiles live in what is called a
pattern table
so the eight kilobytes of graphics data
that you have is enough storage space
for you to fit two pattern tables for
your game
and each pattern table holds
256 tiles there's that number again
um
literally everything that your game will
ever draw to the screen
must be located in one of these two
pattern tables if your game wants to
draw text to the screen you need to
include a font as some of your 512 tiles
that you have access to
these are the pattern tables from super
mario brothers for the nes literally
everything super mario brothers will
ever draw to the screen
is right here
we also get a little bit more abstract
by using layers so here is a screen from
super mario brothers what is actually
happening here is we've got two layers
superimposed over the top of each other
we have a background layer on the left
which is for things that are not really
going to move around a whole lot the
background layer can scroll left or
right or up and down
but the tiles in the background are
locked into a grid you can't just put
them anywhere
the sprites meanwhile are for things
that are going to move around a lot
that's usually where you see your player
character enemy characters things like
that
much more limited because sprites can be
put anywhere down to the pixel
so i'm going to start by talking about
backgrounds
so as i mentioned it's a grid it's 32
tiles wide it's 30 tiles tall multiply
that together you've got 960 tiles in a
screen and you need one byte for every
tile because you need to know which tile
from 0 to 255 goes in that slot in the
grid
um so you can fit an entire background
in 960 bytes because you only need to
reference the tiles not individual
pixels you actually have enough space to
hold two screens in memory at the same
time by doing it this way
uh as far as the sprites are concerned
they're handled a little bit differently
you get 256 bytes of ram just for
sprites and it takes four bytes to store
a single spray tile because you need to
know the x and y position on the screen
exactly of where that sprite's going to
go
um so you divide that out you can have
64 sprites on screen at one time which
sounds pretty big but eight by eight
pixels is very small so like small mario
here is actually four sprite tiles
working together to show you a single
image
um
technically you can have 64 sprites in
reality you're probably going to have a
far smaller number of actual objects
moving around
that's how we handle a single screen
single screens work for donkey kong it
doesn't have to scroll or do anything
but a lot of nes games do
a popular one is super mario brothers i
apologize if i feel like it's the only
thing i'm talking about i swear there
will be other things um
this is world one one this is the first
stage of super mario bros it is 14
screens in length
so we need 14 screens of graphics it's
960 bytes per background uh that's about
13 kilobytes of level data that we have
to encode somewhere
we get 32k to store all of our game code
which means you can fit your 13k and
still have plenty of room left over for
like what happens when i press buttons
on the controller and things like that
but that's just the first stage
um here it is again
we also need to worry about uh one two
one three one four two one two two two
three
two four
and then we have to do that four more
times because super mario brothers has
32 stages and they are all 10 plus
screens in length
um so you got a big game how do you fit
that into 32k because super mario
brothers is only 32k of game code
the answer unsurprisingly is you get
even more abstract than we already have
um one way to do this is you use these
kind of repeated meta objects in your
backgrounds uh this is a screen from the
metal man stage of mega man 2. uh
there's a lot going on here but really
all that's happening is you've got these
three blocks on the right side which are
each two by two tiles and the whole
background is just those three blocks
repeated
so we've gone even another layer beyond
from pixels to tiles to now multi-tile
things
you can use a kind of basic compression
for the nes
it's not very powerful on the math front
so compression for the nes is usually
some kind of run length encoding
something like i've got this thing
that's going to repeat a certain number
of times and then i've got like a very
tight little for loop kind of thing that
can just
draw that thing repeatedly into video
ram
in the case of super mario brothers we
get even
further beyond um super mario brothers
features what people who have analyzed
the code like to call set decoration um
so here you've got three screens
arranged left to right
these three screens repeat endlessly in
the background of many stages
so take a moment notice the pattern of
clouds in the sky notice the pattern of
the hills and bushes on the ground
so as you start looking at super mario
brothers you start seeing here's six
screens in a row from that first stage
and those clouds repeat in a pattern and
those hills and bushes repeat in a
pattern
what set decoration allows super mario
brothers to do is the only level data
you actually need to store is what are
the things that are different from that
set decoration you only need to store
the things that get laid on top of it
so super mario brothers stores world one
one in 101 bytes it is tiny compared to
the 13 kilobytes we talked about before
the code has a header and a footer which
tells the game where the level data
starts and ends and then in the middle
it has these pairs of bytes and each
pair is a location on screen and what to
draw there
so the first pair
0 7 says go to column 0 row 7 of the
screen and then draw 81 says draw a
question mark block that has a coin in
it or go to column four row seven and
draw a row of four bricks
it's a very compact format which is how
you're able to fit
32 stages into a very small amount of
space
so that's graphics uh let's move on to
physics
uh
jumping stuff like that
so back to the atari 2600 i think the
most
good looking technically impressive game
for the atari 2600 is probably pitfall
um
looks pretty good for an atari 2600 game
uh the main thing to notice though is
our hero i believe he's called pitfall
harry um
he runs at a constant speed
um he has a jump but it doesn't really
feel like a real jump he kind of does
this weightless sort of float thing
and this came out in 1982 so you go
three years later when super mario
brothers comes out and mario has weight
he accelerates smoothly over time he's
not just always in a run
um if you are moving in one direction
and then you turn around to go the other
way he skids to a stop before he starts
moving in the other direction
one of the things that made this game
really impressive for its time was that
there mario has a feeling of weight when
you play with him
what makes this interesting is the 6502
is not really known for math it can do
four math operations it can do addition
subtraction
and it can do these bit shifts left and
right which are basically multiply and
divide by two and anything that is not
in this list that you wanna do you need
to write a function or a subroutine
that does that you want to multiply by
three you need to write a function that
multiplies by three in terms of addition
and subtraction and bit shifts
and
physics type equations usually need more
than just adding and subtracting so how
do you get that kind of physics feel
when you don't have any of the math
power to do it the real way
uh super mario brothers many other games
like it fake it unsurprisingly
um you may have heard of floating point
numbers or floats where you can have any
number of digits on the left or right of
the decimal point
for super mario brothers they use fixed
point fractions and they call them 8.8
because you've got eight bits on the
left you've got eight bits on the right
and that's all you can use
um basically they just track every
position using two bytes the first byte
is like that left byte and that's your
actual on-screen pixel position for
where mario is going to be drawn
and the second byte is a sub-pixel you
use it to represent like a fraction of a
real pixel
um
you could have any anything in like one
256th of a pixel super mario brothers
doesn't even care about all that it just
uses multiples of 16 which is enough to
give them like a resolution of 1 16 of a
pixel for how fast things are moving
where on screen things are located
anything like that
using this relatively simple system
gives them that smooth acceleration
curve because you can add fractions of a
pixel every frame and get something that
looks like a realistic movement
before i leave physics we should talk a
little bit more about collision
detection
also an important thing for many games
to do
and i think the best game to talk about
collision detection with is probably
contra
it was an nes port of a popular konami
arcade game the box art is a complete
and total ripoff of late 80s arnold
schwarzenegger sylvester stallone action
movies
including featuring like the character
from alien in the middle
um
notably for the nes it allows for
two-player simultaneous play
so each player can have their own
controller and they can be on screen
doing stuff together at the same
time contra is a game that moves very
fast
so there's a lot of things running
around the screen there's a lot of
bullets flying all over the place
and each of these things need to have
collision detection because you need to
know did a bullet hit an enemy did an
enemy bullet hit the player like lots of
things need to be checked against each
other
one of the other things that makes this
difficult is there's just a wide variety
of shapes so the player character can be
standing up in a vertical position they
can be lying down flat on the ground
they can be jumping which makes them
like a little round shape
the enemies also come in a wide variety
of shapes and sizes
so if you're going to do these
comparisons against each other the like
the bounding boxes you would normally
use to detect a collision are going to
constantly be changing
which for a system that can only do
addition and subtraction is challenging
so
to show you like the extreme level of
this um this is a boss fight from about
halfway through the game that's being
done in two player the players together
have managed to put 11 bullets on screen
at the same time those are those little
white arrows
there are four possible enemy positions
that they could hit with those bullets
which are the little gold arrows
so
every frame of graphics because contra
is running at 60 frames a second
we need to check all 11 bullets against
all four enemies and then we need to
check all four enemies against both
players separately
which is a lot of work to do in 16
milliseconds
um so how do you do this when you've got
lots of objects and you need to do this
in real time
the developers of contra came up with a
really interesting solution
they decided that the fastest way to do
collision detection is point versus
rectangle
so one thing is represented by a single
point the other one is a rectangle and
you just check is this point inside the
rectangle if it is collision we're good
and they decided to make the player
always always always be the point no
matter what
so here you can see three different
collision detection scenarios and
there's a little green dot with a green
circle around it that is the point that
represents the player for collision
detection
and there's this little white plus sign
shaped thing that is an enemy bullet
that we're going to do a collision
detection with and what they did is the
player is always the point the enemy is
always the rectangle and the rectangle
changes based on what position the
player is in
so all you need to store for your
enemies is
um
like what is the offset of the box
relative to where the enemy actually is
and then it just changes with the player
shape and it lets you do this really
pretty fast
i think it's a good time to talk about
random numbers
um
less games need random numbers than you
might think
most nes games most games in general
until relatively recently are very
deterministic where like things are laid
out in a particular way and how you
press buttons on the controller
ultimately is what affects what happens
not any sense of randomness
but there are games that need random
numbers
puzzle games tetris
lives or dies by its random numbers
because literally the entire game is you
don't know what piece is going to come
next and you have to figure out how to
deal with it
role playing games like final fantasy
need good random numbers because they're
kind of simulating dice rolls all the
time so you're walking around you know
do you end up fighting some monsters
randomly if you do what monsters are
there who do they try to hit do they
actually hit them how much damage do
they do all these calculations you need
to do with random numbers all the time
um so in any kind of modern language the
way you would do this is you've got some
kind of system library call that lets
you get a random number from some source
of randomness so if you're using
javascript you call math.random and you
multiply and floor and that gives you
a random number between zero and 255
which is cool
the nes doesn't have a random number
generator it doesn't have anything built
into the system so if your game needs
random numbers you need to come up with
your own method of generating random
numbers and every game kind of does it
differently
so the next problem we have is
how do you do that
i'm going to show you three approaches
i have ordered these three approaches in
order from least to most
stupid um
uh
the best one probably is tetris not
really surprising um tetris does it with
math which is probably the way you
should do it uh they use this construct
called a 16-bit fibonacci linear
feedback shift register which is a
complicated way of saying you have two
bytes of memory you do these weird
bit-to-bit comparisons within your two
bytes and then you shift things around
in particular ways
and that gives you a fairly convincing
stream of pseudo-random numbers
uh final fantasy takes a different
approach
uh final fantasy if you've ever played
it there's this great bit
relatively early in the game where you
cross a bridge and you get this cut
scene which is amazing for the time
where it tells you your heroes are going
on this amazing quest etc etc and at one
point it says programmed by nasser and
as a kid i was playing this i was like
oh this must be like some company that
they subcontracted out to
no it turns out nasser is actually
nasser gibeli it's this guy
who
emigrated from iran to japan and then
was hired by squaresoft as a contractor
and he wrote the entirety of final
fantasy's game code all by himself
he was very busy um
he needed a way to get random numbers
and so he did what anyone would do and
he hard coded a table
of 256 pre-computed random numbers
um so final fantasy has this table in
its game code and then it has one byte
that it uses as a pointer into this
table and every time final fantasy needs
a random number it bumps the pointer up
by one and looks up the next number out
of the table
which sounds really dumb um
but it kind of works like i've never
played final fantasy before and been
like oh like this is just looking up
numbers out of a table who wants that
um so that's approach number two
and approach number three is actually
from contra believe it or not
um contra needs random numbers to
determine when to randomly spawn these
soldier enemies that run in from the
left and right sides of the screen
um
it's not like a huge use of random
numbers if things go badly you're not
really going to notice
um so contra has the stupidest approach
of all contra's approach is there is one
byte of memory that stores your current
random number and when contra is not
busy doing something else like collision
detection it figures out the current
frame number and it adds that into the
random byte as fast as it possibly can
until the next frame of graphics starts
and then it stops
and that's your random number
um so if you're currently on frame seven
of graphics it's just going to add seven
over and over and over and over again
until it needs to do something else and
then wherever it stops is the number
that you get
um which is the worst random number
generator sequence of any of these that
i've shown you and again for contra
it works like
eventually you see enemies running in
and out and you really don't think about
it
one more thing to talk about is how you
save your game
um
a frequent thing that i have yelled at
people when i was playing nes games that
did not have good saving mechanisms
um
when these games were in the arcade like
if you go to play donkey kong in the
arcade
the expectation is your game session is
not going to last very long if you can
play
five minutes of donkey kong on a single
quarter you're halfway decent like
that's good
um but as these games move into the home
those expectations change because now
people are putting in a huge chunk of
money up front for a game that they are
going to be stuck with forever
unless they sell it or something um but
people start expecting a lot more out of
their games they want something that
they feel is going to be worth their
money where they can get a lot of time
and enjoyment out of things and so you
start seeing games where it's not just a
simple tight little arcade loop it's
like bigger broader more expansive
stories
the problem is you are on a read-only
cartridge you don't have any way to
write your game data anywhere
so
early nes games they try to get around
this with passwords um
good example mega man 2 uses this kind
of system where there's a grid you put
these little red balls in the grid and
that lets you pick up where you left off
so every time you finish a stage it will
display to you this grid and you can
pull out your notebook and you can hand
draw here's the grid here's where
everything goes
and then get back to it
this system is very simple it always
uses nine of these red balls and they
are just a literal one to one
ratio of
is each boss alive or dead and how many
of these energy tanks that you can pick
up only once have you picked up during
the game
if you play enough games of mega man 2
and you write down enough of these
passwords you can eventually figure it
out and just make your own password for
whatever you want
um
an alternative approach is punch out
punch out you get a password which is 10
digits it's basically a phone number
it's set up 334 even
um
nintendo really really did not want you
to reverse engineer this password system
they were like i don't want anyone
coming and being like okay i figured it
out i just put in this number and that
gets me exactly where i want
punch out has a fiendishly complicated
password system where it takes all the
data about what you've done so far in
the game stores those into particular
bytes and then scrambles them around and
mangles them with each other to end up
at a password
there's a great article here that goes
into way more depth than i have time for
surprisingly dragon quest 2
a big long rpg playing this game takes
you like 30 to 40 hours and you are not
going to just keep the system on the
entire time until that is done
um it needs to save data about this
giant world and you have three different
characters who each have their own stats
there's a lot of stuff to keep track of
in japan dragon quest 2 uses passwords
so whenever you go to save your game it
gives you what is essentially a poem
that you again copy down into a notebook
somewhere and then you come back and you
type in the poem using this grid which
if you've ever tried to like search for
a movie on netflix using your remote
control is maddening um
people don't like these password systems
they want something better
so nintendo says okay
how about we come up with an alternative
the original alternative they come up
with is called the famicom disk system
it comes out in japan in 1986.
it is this giant red box which is a disk
drive that sits underneath your famicom
and they start selling games for it that
come on these discs and they're writable
disks that are bigger than a game
cartridge so you can fit something like
120 kilobytes or something like that on
one of these disks and they're writable
so you can save your game anywhere and
just write as much data as you want
they have this little tab at the bottom
that says nintendo
then as now nintendo was paranoid about
copy protection so this little tab at
the bottom the eye and one of the ends
are actually physically indented into
the plastic and inside the drive there's
a metal plate that has a little eye and
a little end that need to fit into those
depressions and if the plate doesn't fit
just right it refuses to play the game
because it's like clearly you are doing
something shady
uh the problem for nintendo is that they
chose a disc format that was in common
use at the time it was called the
mitsumi quick disc um didn't really see
a lot of release in the us but in japan
it was popular for things like word
processors or like early computers of
the day
uh 2.8 inch discs here they are with a
save icon for size reference
um
you could buy these you could just go to
a store and buy some quick discs and it
did not take long for japanese players
to figure out that with a little home
modification you could turn these quick
disks into something that the disk
system would read as a real game
um it got so bad that by the end of 1986
you had companies that were literally
putting out discs that already had those
little indentations in them because they
knew what you were trying to do
um
nintendo did not like this
shocker uh so they went back to the
drawing board how do you allow people to
save their game data when you don't want
them to copy it
so they went back to cartridges
um they came up with there's a new
little chip here called the mmc one
which allows you to slap on a battery
and another chip full of ram
and that battery just gives you a little
trickle of electricity that keeps the
contents of the ram alive even when it's
not in your system so now you've got an
extra eight kilobytes that you can just
write whatever you want to
which leads us to another problem
um you start seeing this like in game
manuals or in actual games themselves um
you'll see things where it's like hold
in the reset button as you turn the
power off very important you will
destroy your game if you don't do this
what is going on with this well
uh it turns out when you turn off the
power to your nes it doesn't just go
from on to off immediately
what actually happens is you turn off
the power and the processor still has a
little bit of residual electricity in it
and that just
fades away
relatively quickly but it's enough time
that like the processor is still running
and as the processor has less and less
electricity available to it it starts
acting more and more erratic
so it's unlikely
but it is possible that as you turn off
your system that processor is going to
do something totally unpredictable and
write data into that save ram and just
corrupt everything that you've put there
so you start seeing these warnings
because holding the reset button puts
that processor into a very tight little
loop where it can't break out and do
something else
but if you're a game developer you don't
know
that your player actually did this
you don't know
if the ram has been messed with or not
so
how do you do that because you want to
load the save data but you also don't
want to load something that's been
turned into garbage
um
dragon warrior the us release of dragon
quest 1 did a really interesting thing
where they just write the save file many
many times so i think they make
something like eight copies of your save
into that save ram and they write a
little checksum with each of those
so when dragon warrior goes to load your
save game it reads the first one it
checks the checksum and if they match
cool it will load your game
if they don't it just goes to the next
one and the next one and the next one
and if it goes through all of them and
all of them are bad then it just shows
you like the standard title screen that
says start a new game
but this is how it gets around that like
did you hold the reset button or not
problem
so i've been up here talking to you for
about half an hour now
you may be wondering what is the point
of all of this why are you rambling at
us about these old games
um
there are a number of reasons but uh i
think the one that really kind of sticks
out to me is
doing all this research learning all
these things about all these old games
has shown me that there is value in
embracing the stupid
uh what i mean by that is
you can have a problem that you need to
solve and you can come up with a really
dumb solution to it that does what you
need to do
and that's fine there is nothing wrong
with that
eventually you might find a situation
that proves to you that your situation
is too dumb and it doesn't solve
everything you need to do and at that
point you can go back and you can change
it but up to that point
just get things done ship them out the
door who cares um
i would rather
hard code a table of 256 random numbers
and ship final fantasy
then sit there for months trying to
figure out the perfect random number
generating algorithm
that's my takeaway you may have your own
that's the bulk of what i've got if this
is something that you are interested in
if you want to know more about how the
nes works developing for it anything
like that uh i'm going to show you some
resources uh one i will definitely point
to is nathan altus's book i am error
from 2015.
this is part of an mit press book series
called platform studies the whole series
is great this book in particular goes
into the design decisions that led to
the nes in the state it was actually
released in
fantastic book this is the book that got
me into doing this in the first place
if you want to drink from the fire hose
there is the nes dev wiki um there is a
community of people who still make nes
games to this day brand new games you
can buy on hardware and play in an
actual nes console
the nes dev wiki is like the central
place for information about everything
about how the nes works
uh if you want to start writing your own
code
this is actually my site i've been
working on a tutorial series slash book
kind of thing for a couple of years now
um i will walk you through how to make
nes games in assembly and my only
assumption is that you have worked in
some kind of programming language before
javascript python ruby whatever does not
matter like you know what a variable is
and what a for loop is
that's all you need
um
eternally in progress but there is
enough here that like you can get a
super solid introduction to go look at
other people's code and understand
what's going on
and that's that's basically it so thank
you again all of you uh please stay in
touch
please stay in touch this is my email
address if you want to get in touch with
me there is also as i mentioned there is
a slack chat room just for this talk if
you have any questions post them there
i'll be answering them
for as long as i'm able to
so the question was final fantasy has
the table of random numbers how do you
not get the same game every single time
the initial seed pointer into the table
i think is based on something like how
many frames you wait before you press
start at the title screen
um
so if you use something like an emulator
where you have save states um you can
save a state of the game and reload it
and every single time you'll be like
okay i know i am seven steps away from
getting into a fight and this is exactly
what is going to happen every single
time
um but it's that uh from startup when
you first hit that power button that's
how it seeds that number
you can um i simplified a little bit
there um but as far as like the nes
hardware is concerned it just knows
there are two pattern tables one is
sprites one is backgrounds
chips like that mmc one that enables you
to do saving let you put in more than
eight kilobytes of graphics data you can
only expose eight kilobytes to the
system at a time but you can like change
which eight kilobytes it's seeing
um there are also later chips that
enabled you to set up instead of chr rom
where it's like baked in you could do
chr ram where you could literally just
write in real time what goes into those
pattern tables
um there are games like battle toads or
metal storm that use that to do these
really complicated parallax effects
because they're constantly redrawing
what is in the tiles while you're
playing
you can to some degree um there is a
decently sized community of people who
use c to write nes games there is
basically a c library that
you use the functions in the c library
and then it can compile down into 6502
assembly
there's a guy named douglas freaker i
believe who
has like a whole tutorial series on c
development for the nes
i i heard about that one recently i have
not had a chance to poke around uh i
don't think i am the person to give a
talk about that
but it sounds super cool yeah
someone asked how does the game genie
work
the game genie literally just kind of
intercepts in between the cartridge and
the system and it allows you to like
overwrite ram values so like the
cartridge code will say hey do this to
the ram inside the nes and the game
genie will intercept that message and
actually set it to something else
instead
game genie has its own complicated
password system of how the password you
type in turns into like what to do to a
particular ram address
how long until the ram battery dies uh
really depends i'm not sure um i own
some nes games that as far as i know
still have the original battery in them
and work just fine other people they
definitely die it's kind of hit or miss
okay and then i've got one other
question here shouldn't the random
number multiply by 256 uh i believe this
is about final fantasy
i'm not entirely sure what the question
is
oh the javascript one uh
possibly i might have done that wrong in
which case thank you for pointing that
out
all right it looks like i am at time
so like i said i will take a look in
slack i'll try to respond to everyone
who has a question and if not please
stay in touch thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you